yeah thanks casey as you heard casey
just say texas governor greg abbott not
waiting for the administration to fix
this mess he's deploying ten thousand
state troopers and national guard
members to uh for as another caravan
heads uh to the u.s so lieutenant chris
oliveiras with the texas department of
public safety is now joining us
appreciate it thank you for your work
down there first of all second of all
will this be enough
hey lars good morning thanks for having
me so well i can tell you right now the
thousands that we've already deployed as
far as national guardsmen and state
troopers uh to the southern border has
been effective it's been an effective
strategy to what we're doing to try to
secure the border we've made thousands
of arrests we've we've seized thousands
of drugs and as far as currency uh just
within the past three weeks we've seized
over 1.6 million dollars of currency
that was making its way south uh into
mexico to supply the cartels but we
talked about mass migration
as far as the reinstatement of the
remaining mexico policy that's the
remains to be seen we're 10 months into
this crisis and i can tell you right now
the criminal organizations smuggling
organizations are profiting off this
crisis and i can tell you it's going to
be very difficult for them just to sit
back and close up shop that's not going
to happen they're making millions and
millions of dollars a week off of this
crisis just off of human smuggling so
again that remains to be seen how
effective the mexico policy is gonna
it's gonna be uh it's gonna take place
as far as this current crisis goes so
lieutenant you're saying that was 1.6
million
of the illegal proceeds that they were
trying to bring back to the cartelse wow
that is a lot of money um you know how
upsetting is this the fact that federal
government uh has largely ignored the
situation on the southern border and
it's falling under your shoulders
well i can tell you right now that uh at
least with as far as the state agency
goes as far as texas dps uh the morale
for our state troopers is at an all-time
high i mean we have great support
tremendous support from governor greg
abbott from our texas legislatures from
our state leadership because we have the
resources to take care of this problem
but the issue is that the federal
government is stepping in and they're
not allowing us to do our jobs because
there's certain areas especially on
federal property that we cannot take
enforcement action because the federal
government does not want us to take
enforcement action so that's one thing
that the american people need to
understand is that we're more than ready
we have the resources we have the assets
to step in and secure the border but
again the question needs to be asked of
the federal government as to why you're
not allowing texas to step in and take
care of this crisis if you're not going
to do it yeah exactly so you know in
october of 2021 i know you're well aware
but there were 164 303 encounters at the
southern border according to cbp and
that's more than double from october of
2020 so numbers like these is that
playing into the it is playing in the
president's approval rating the latest
fox news poll shows 59 of registered
voters disapprove of how the president's
handling the border that's 59
so it's been a major failure of the
federal government
you know how do you in your opinion
quickly stop these caravans from coming
well it's a messaging i can tell you
that right now lawrence it's the
messaging the messaging from day one
from the federal government has been
come to the border because you will be
released to the country and that's why
we're seeing this mass migration taking
place the numbers have not decreased and
the data shows that so long as the
messaging is still out there and also
the criminal organizations use that
messaging to their advantage because
they want to profit off of this crisis
so they're going to continue telling
these illegal immigrants to make it to
the border to make it to the u.s because
you will be released to the country and
when they see that when friends and
families have made that journey and
they're released into the country they
know that's going to take place and now
not only that but with the messaging as
far as incentivizing uh those that they
claim were separated from the previous
years incentivizing them with 450
thousand dollars ahead
that's not that's not going to resolve
the current crisis right now that's just
it's just going to make it worse it's
going to continue to escalate that's
what we're seeing yeah i want to ask you
too about this here we're dealing with a
new variant now of covid we're on pace
for more than a million people to cross
the border illegally uh you know and
that's more than the population of some
states how many crossings do you believe
has cova do we know and it's a health
risk too isn't it
it is a health person that's one thing
that we don't know and that's that's the
scary part of it right there lawrence is
that we don't know how many of these
illegal immigrants were released and we
listened to the country that weren't
tested for covet we know the vast
majority weren't especially until real
when we had the situation back in
september with the haitians you know
over 12 000 that were released into the
country again we don't know how many or
if any of all were tested for covet so
that is a national health issue not only
for the state of texas but for the
entire country so that's one thing that
we need to be very concerned about as
this crisis continues to continue to
happen sure in the last 30 seconds
lieutenant what about offering them
vaccinations we're hearing that the
biden administration will uh you know
allow them to have a shot before they go
back for the remaining mexico policy
will that just bring people more people
to the border who want to get that shot
you know that's what we've foreseen i
think that's that's that's what i
believe is going to happen um i think
that should have been taking place from
day one right when you're releasing
thousands and thousands of illegal
immigrants into the country and you're
not vaccinated you're not testing them
for covert and we're still we're still
at the at the at the uh at the height of
this uh pandemic right now where we're
still seeing uh covet spreading
throughout the entire country but again
that should have been that should have
been taking place from day one i think
it's only going to continue to motivate
these illegal immigrants to make that
journey uh because now they're going to
be coveted and as long as this this
crisis has taken place i can tell you
we're now lawrence the smuggling
organizations are going to continue to
profit off it they're going to find ways
to smuggle illegal immigrants into the
country right thank you lieutenant
oliveira's keep up the good work down
there appreciate it thank you